the energy Department
with its network of U.S National
Laboratories just revised its assessment
to say with low confidence but
nevertheless they're saying this that
the pandemic very likely began with a
lab leak
remember the first story we told was was
that the pandemic began with a bad batch
of bat soup at a Wuhan wet Market that
just coincidentally was right down the
street from a bio-lab but pay no
attention to that that's a crazy
conspiracy theory already we've got the
National Intelligence Council and four
agencies for other agencies that the
Wall Street Journal refuses to identify
still believes with low confidence in
the natural emergence Theory the Wuhan
wet Market Theory the FBI said two years
ago now with moderate confidence that it
probably began with the lab League the
CIA and two other agencies still have
not quite made a determination but
think we see which way this is trending